imagine a world where we can do
computation inside living cells problem
we're trying to solve is really trying
to have a more sophisticated diagnosis
that can happen automatically inside
cells
imagine a biological computer that
operates inside a living cell so for
example it could be used to determine
whether a cell is cancerous and if so
then trigger the death of the cell so
here we're talking about little
molecular systems that you can you know
work that run in a test tube or maybe
even in the life cell so they're really
small the type of work that they're
doing is essentially they're trying to
sense analyze and control molecular
information in this project we're trying
to use DNA as a programmable material
DNA is highly programmable just like a
computer and we can program a whole
range of complex behaviors using DNA
molecules so we're taking advantage of a
phenomenon called DNA strand
displacement so DNA strand displacement
is essentially a competitive
hybridization reaction so it's two
strands of DNA that come together and as
they bind to one another a third strand
that was initially bound this kicked off
one issue with like any biology
researcher for biomolecular research is
that it's always sort of a cycle of
trial and error you test it it doesn't
work so you go back to the drawing board
and you do that over and over again and
it's a slow cycle because doing
experiments just is hard and it takes a
lot of time
we developed a language for programming
molecular circuits made of DNA so the
programmer would write down a collection
of DNA strands and the software work out
how these DNA strands interact with each
other and can be used to predict their
behavior over time and this kind of
software could for example be used to
detect and fix bugs in a molecular
circuit design before that circuit is
built for decades biologists have been
using chemical reaction networks as a
means of describing the behavior of
biological systems so what our
technology enables for the first time is
that any system described as a chemical
reaction network can now be translated
implemented in biology at the molecular
level one of the things that we've done
recently which I'm particularly excited
about is that we have created designed
using a tool and created experimentally
is an implementation of the so-called
approximate majority algorithm at the
moment really der the technology is very
much in its infancy is still very much
at the research stage so most of what
we're doing is in is in the test tube an
enormous goal will be to have what were
able to do in the test tube also working
inside cells that's a hugely enormous
challenge so this could enable a whole
range of Barre technology applications
for example it could allow us to both
detect and treat disease to a level of
precision that has not been possible so
far it could also allow us to make new
compounds far more efficiently these
compounds could be medicines or
biomaterials and ultimately it can allow
us to make biological computers that
operate at the molecular scale
you